la faille qu'à ce jour là il n'y a pas
de problème était pas jaloux il disait
un mec comme chamfort ils tombent toutes
les filles qui veulent lui dès le départ
il avait pris les prix sont partis
ouais j'sais pas pourquoi desire ouais
c'est un peu gratuit vous moi j'ai
jamais été un plus démonstratif un seul
sujet la cua jeudi un geste pour au
contraire j'ai toujours essayé de garder
ma vie privée ou femmes amenées à hors
de propos professionnels comédiens j'ai
été très discret donc vous avez fait
ensemble vocal rose n'a pas eu un grand
succès oui pas de succès du succès du
tout fondées pause puis alors appris du
manouls rêva à la cité nord est et sur
quinze mais aussi paradoxalement ça va
paraître manureva avant attaque à ce
point tube au succès de 45 jours et
l'album soit cas il était bon et avait
quand même que les six ou sept ou huit
autres titres n'a pas marché du tout
s'est mal terminée avec un jeu bourrin
parce que comme il l'avait fait aux
armes et caetera série croyait beaucoup
à la spontanéité ça
il travaille et - quoi des toits tu
avais l'impression qu'ils te laisser
tomber puis un jour il est parti
carrément fait 102 titres sur les bras
non je vais pas voter mais au moment où
on a commencé à parler ensemble j'ai
senti qu'il y avait qu il avait donné
quelque chose là qu'il travaillait je
voyais souvent il y avait des ébauches
de textes puis on y retravaille am
legend l'encouragent à la filiale est
vraiment un sentiment j'ai trouvé
vraiment sentiment qu'il avait envie de
le faire sérieusement
et quand on a des partis pour faire
amour année zéro c'est vrai que sa
technique de travail avait vraiment
changer l'image que comme il avait le
code connu le succès ce soir ou jamais
cette erreur en impro wilaya en vue
d'adapter sa tous les cas et j'ai dû moi
ça fonctionnait manger quoi enfin c'est
là que tu as fait tes grands trucs
énormes que j'adore ah ouais il
yad'ailleurs n'y a pas que moi ça même
été repris par sergio mendes manhattan
transfer sont une fatigue vraiment
finalement s'envoler cette fois des
gosses à la vente
ouais mais j'ai préféré lier et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus